today the Matt Walsh show a
heartbreaking clip goes viral showing
the total devastation that gender
ideology reeks on families also DeSantis
finally directly responds to Trump's
attacks though his response is not
nearly as dramatic as the media is
making out to be Joe Biden tries to read
poetry and it goes as well as you'd
expect the governor of Arizona focuses
on the real issues by outlawing quote
hair discrimination Media Matters comes
up with their latest attack on The Daily
wire this time they're mad that we don't
like to do laundry in our daily
cancellation it comes to this finally I
must cancel my daily wire colleague
Michael Knowles all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know spring is just around the
corner and the last thing you need is
those pesky sun spots on your skin when
you're outside soaking up the Sun for
the first time ever our friends at
genucel are including both the ultra
retinol and Dark Spot Corrector in their
most popular package at genucel.com
Welsh join yourselves Ultra retinol
package contains a powerful retinal
alternative that is safe for your skin
their Dark Spot Corrector will help you
help with all those sunspots plus you'll
still get genusel's world-class under
eye bags therapy for that annoying under
eye bags and puffiness with gender cells
immediate effects you'll see results in
12 hours guaranteed or your money back
you know my Show's director Mark Jones
uses we just keep going through uh
people who work on the show uses genu
sales Ultra retinal treatment after
directing my show Daily this gentle
wrinkle treatment helps soothe and
smooth any lines I may or may not cause
with all the Havoc I reek on the control
room so we're supposed to imagine now
the you know the crew in the control
room just lathering up with lotion after
every show it's a kind of a bizarre
image but don't worry about that don't
wait visit genucel.com Walsh to save
over 70 off their most popular package
plus every order subscription includes a
luxury gift box with two free Springtime
Essentials just in time for spring
you'll get uh free shipping plus a
Luxury Box containing two free gifts
with every subscription go to
geniusell.com
one of the most important websites in
existence right now is a sub stack
called parents with inconvenient truths
about trans or pit it's a forum where
parents who have felt the devastation of
gender ideology up close and personal
can discuss their experiences
it does not make for fun reading I can
tell you in fact it's some of the most
some of the most heart-wrenching some of
the saddest material you're likely to
ever come across but it's also some of
the most important so this week the lead
story on Pitt is an article written by
an anonymous father with the title a
father's anger that will not sleep and
here's what he writes in part quote
it's been two years since my 19 year old
son walked into a Planned Parenthood and
received HRT drugs on informed consent
his mother and I pleaded with him to not
make such a life-changing decision at
such a young age but he would not listen
to reason and receive these drugs
without without any psychological
evaluation or supervision and little
medical supervision
since that time I have experienced bouts
of intense anger which have caused my
mental health to decline it's an anger
that woke me up at 2 am for nearly a
year and still regularly wakes me up at
4 AM it has taken a toll on my mind my
body and mood I experience depression
and anhedonia more often than not I find
little to know joy and hobbies I once
relished I take care of the tasks of
daily living and not much else I
honestly did not think it was possible
to feel such emotional pain
now here we see all the painfully
familiar themes a young person sucked
into the gender cult and able to make
self-destructive light life-altering
decisions while the parents frantically
scramble to pull them back from the
brink but over time they begin to feel
that uh that the the fight is hopeless
because all of the cultural forces are
arrayed against them in this fight the
father continues quote I am aging and
hope for the compensation of feeling I
had a life well LED and that I
successfully launched my children into
the world but my son has stolen that
from me and left me feeling like an
utter failure this was a child that I
treated with love compassion and
generosity and he has selfishly taken
all of that away
I am aware of how this anger is harming
my mind and body what am I trying to do
about it for the better part of the year
I pleaded with my son to stop his
response was to call his mother and I
transphobic every day for the past two
years I've restrained myself from
sending my son a nasty email telling him
what I really think about his
narcissistic behavior and misogynistic
fantasy
some days I successfully pretend none of
this is happening I enjoy those few
moments of morning amnesia where I can't
get recall my current circumstances I
saw a therapist for about a year and a
half but it wasn't helpful part of me
always saw the therapist as part of the
profession enabling the social Contagion
I also couldn't trust him with my true
feelings as I feared judgment
several times a week I have a crying Jag
that lasts several minutes I do it when
my wife is out walking the dog so as to
not burden her with this
if I didn't love my son all of this
would be much easier but I do
and it is my love that causes the grief
that feeds my anger
now he also notes that he will never
vote Democrat again which is another
common theme in many of these stories
this is the side of gender ideology that
is rarely acknowledged
almost never discussed
transgenderism leaves nothing but
destruction in its wake and it's not
just the individual gender-confused
person who is irreparably harmed by it
they are but it's also everyone around
that person everyone who loves him
this week we've seen this dramatically
Illustrated in a viral clip from the Dr
Phil show now this clip is from an
episode that first aired several years
ago but it started making the rounds on
Twitter just recently it's now been
viewed nearly 10 million times and in
the clip
a trans identified male Reveals His
female Persona to the man who cared for
him since he was a baby now that man is
actually his biological uncle but took
on the role of the boy's father when he
was a newborn and has raised him as a
son ever since so he is the father and
now this father is seeing his son in his
woman face costume for the first time
and he is devastated by it watch
foreign
[Applause]
thank you for being here I appreciate it
tell me what your
thinking and feeling right now Carrie
I'm hurt bad
really bad
what do you what do you have to say why
I just I just want you to know that you
didn't do anything wrong
he didn't do anything wrong
he feels like he lets you down he's gone
back to the point of
he says one time for Halloween yeah
talk about that
keep
he dressed up
like a girl
that I thought it was 40. at first now I
certainly don't
I thought it was Halloween
you know so I just went along with it
actually pinched him on his behind and
said he made a good looking girl but I
was only joking
he's not a good looking girl
he's a very beautiful man
one of the most gut-wrenching videos
you'll ever see made all the more tragic
by the trained seals in the audience
applauding and cheering the very thing
that has broken this man's heart
now I don't know how this moment ended
up on TV or why the man Gary agreed to
go through with this on camera or if he
even knew what he was getting into which
I doubt but
whatever the case there is much to be
learned here and we can learn first from
the entirely predictable reaction from
trans activists who have responded to
this clip by of course the writing and
mocking the father
um because these are soulless heartless
ghouls who just think that his misery is
funny
now of course most of these people have
done the same thing to their own
families and so when they attack the
father they're really rationalizing
their own behavior this is the case
whatever a trans activist says I mean
whatever the trans activist says about
anything
they're always really talking about
themselves because all they care about
is themselves gender ideology is
narcissism through and through it is
narcissism distilled down to its purest
form
it is narcissism elevated to a way of
life
and the narcissist doesn't worry about
how his decisions impact anyone else he
sees the devastation and heartbreak of a
loving father and feels nothing nothing
except anger at the father for daring to
have feelings and priorities of his own
gender ideology teaches the
trans-identified individual that the
entire world exists simply to affirm him
and to prop up and support his
self-perception however deluded it may
be
and since the entire world exists for
this purpose so too does his own family
and the job of each of his family
members as he sees it starting
especially with his parents is to be a
soulless faceless automaton programmed
to accept whatever he does and believe
whatever he says and affirm every
fantasy he has in his head
he demands that his deepest desires be
affirmed and his individual expression
be respected but he doesn't care at all
about the desires hopes dreams
perceptions of the very people he is
making this demand of
he doesn't care about that
I mean they have feelings too but that
never comes into that never makes it
into the equation does it
this is what the gender ideologue
believes it's what their religion
preaches it's one of their Central
creeds
gender ideologies most public proponents
are very clear about this you know they
tell young people that if your parents
offer the slightest resistance to your
desire to quote transition then your
parents are the enemy your parents are
trying to get you killed and you should
cut them out of your life completely
Jeffrey Marsh creepy groomer social
media influencer is Infamous for telling
kids to go quote no contact or
non-contact with their parents
meaning cut them out of your life
but don't worry Marsh says because if
you disown your parents
you can always replace them with Jeffrey
Marsh
your parents screwed up
it's okay to say so that's why I made a
patreon so that we could talk about it
so we could connect in a way that has
more privacy
so that we could talk to each other in a
way that's a more open and stuff that we
wouldn't share like in the comments of a
video like this
I think you're worthy
and valuable and I wanted to spend more
time with you healing together and
hearing your deeply inspiring stories
yes he wants to connect with you for the
low price of a patreon subscription
Jeffrey Marsh will be your new father
figure or mother figure or whatever the
hell he's trying to be
forget about the people who conceived
you and birthed you and raised you from
diapers and gave you everything gave you
their lives gave you their hearts
forget them I mean they obviously hate
you if they won't immediately and
without question except that you are a
sex other than the one on your birth
certificate
Jeffrey Marsh has a real interest at
heart pay him some money and come talk
to him privately online and he'll tell
you all about it
this is why we need to call more
attention to the kallus narcissistic
disregard that the gender ideologue has
for his own loved ones this is as I said
a central feature of the ideology
there's a reason why so many of
transgenderism's most prominent mascots
are you know grown men who quote
transitioned later in life and
intentionally destroyed their marriages
and families in the process
take Rachel Levine for example 65 years
old today it'll be easy to see he
decided to quote come out as a woman in
2011 which means that he was in his
early 50s you know when he made that
decision
he had a wife who had been married to
for years
he had two kids
putting everything else aside just think
about how unfathomably selfish you have
to be how uncaring and heartless to tell
your wife that her husband is gone
and now she has to get used to being
married to a woman and guess what you're
in a lesbian relationship now
whether you like it or not
and to tell your children that their
father is gone they no longer have a
father their father is dead
and now they must simply accept that
they have two moms
consider how disastrously self-absorbed
you must be to put this weight this
burden on your family on those who
depend on you
but what does Levine supposed to do is
he supposed to suppress his deepest
desires and live as a man even if he
doesn't feel like one even if it makes
him uncomfortable
yes of course that's what he's supposed
to do
of course
now this may come as a shock to the left
I know it comes as a shock to them
but there are more important things in
your life than your desires
especially desires that are so deeply
disordered
your responsibility to your family is
one of those things
and now we get to the part that very few
people ever say out loud
um and I I have as you know many
arguments against gender ideology I've
articulated me all of them many times
but here's another point in addition to
those that needs to be acknowledged
you know as we know you cannot be any
sex other than the one you were born as
any attempt to transition is ultimately
doomed to failure it fails before it
even begins
but also not only do you have no choice
but to be the sex that you are you also
have the responsibility
to accept that fact and live accordingly
okay a man has the responsibility to
live as a man and act as a man and a
woman as a woman you have a
responsibility in other words to live in
reality
we are not atomized individuals living
in our own universes divorced from the
next person's uh reality we we have
lives that are intertwined with each
other we in fact do live in a society it
turns out we also live in families and
and our lives are more intertwined the
closer we are tied to each other whether
by blood or by marriage what this means
is that when you decide to totally
reject the non-negotiable realities of
the world and even to reject your own
physical nature you are not making a
neutral decision that affects no one but
yourself you are tied to other people
whether you like it or not and you are
pulling them with you into this Dark
Twisted alternate universe that you have
constructed
you are imposing it on them
that man in the clip is a father that is
a bond that will forever tie him to his
son and forever Define both of them
when the sun decides to be a woman quote
unquote
he is doing that to his father
he's not just radically changing his own
life
he is radically changing his father's
life and demanding that his father be
okay with it
this is my life he might say
but it's not just his life
there are many other lives bound up with
his life and he is seeking to
fundamentally alter all of them
now
if you were some uh some sort of uh
Immortal being that materialized out of
The Ether and was passively you know
floating in space Somewhere Out near the
asteroid belt that it might be true that
your decisions and lifestyle choices
don't affect anyone else okay if you're
just floating out in space and you and
you materialized out there then yes then
you can rightly say well what I do has
no effect on anybody else so what is it
to you
but if you're a human being born to
human parents raised in a family and
living in a community
then nearly everything you do has an
impact on others and that impact is felt
more profoundly the closer someone is to
you
for the guy in that Dr Phil segment
his refusal to live as the person that
he is his denial of reality his
rejection of his basic responsibility as
a man starting with the responsibility
to be a man and act as a man and accept
the fact that he is a man
becomes now a giant cross that everyone
who loves him must carry he has exploded
all of their lives so that he can live
as he wishes
now he may be a victim in his own right
a victim of brainwashing a victim of the
lies that he has come to believe but now
he makes victims of his family
of the people who love him the most
and nothing will ever make that okay
now let's get to our five headlines
Biden's plans to help struggling
business owners in the wake of Kobe
lockdowns were to prioritize black
latino Native American and women-owned
businesses goes without saying that if
the roles were reversed if Biden had
said his plans were to prioritize white
male-owned businesses well there would
be outrage to say the least if you own a
business you can't rely on the
government to bail you out you need to
take matters into your own hands and
Innovation refunds can help you do just
that no matter what demographic group
you belong to if your business has five
or more employees and manage to survive
covid you could be eligible to receive a
payroll tax rebate of up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee through
the employee retention credit just go to
getrefunds.com Innovation refunds has
already helped clients claim over three
billion dollars in payroll tax refunds
through the ERC and they may be able to
help your business too this is not alone
there's no payback it's a refund of your
taxes simple as that there's no upfront
charge either they don't get paid until
you get and your business gets its
refund don't let this opportunity pass
you by see if your business qualifies
for ERC assistance in just eight minutes
go to getrefunds.com click on qualify me
and answer a few questions this payroll
tax refund is only available for a
limited amount of time so don't miss out
go to getrefunds.com getrefunds.com
so we're going to begin here just
because uh well it's great yesterday Joe
Biden attempted to read a poem off of
the teleprompter and uh it went as well
as you might anticipate here it is
Richard Blanco returned to a poem he
wrote from the second inaugural of rock
in me a poem one today says and always
one moon like a silent drum tapping at
every rooftop and every window on every
in of every County
let me start this over again
so intimidated by being here
and always one moon like a silent drum
tapping on every rooftop and every
window of one country a county county
all of us facing the Stars hope a new
constellation waiting for us to map it
waiting for us to name it together
uh it was country by the way he settled
on County finally because he can't read
uh he can't tell the difference between
country and County but it is country
what what do you mean all of us as one
County why would that be the word I mean
even if you're going if you can't read
for some reason going based on context
clues
all of us together as one County
whose idea was this who the hell came up
with the idea that our dementia in Chief
should read a poem who who suggested
that
I want to be in the meeting when that
was suggested
I have to assume it's somebody working
for the other side in which case well
done sir and this must be some sort of
secret agent working uh maybe not so
secret because it's really obvious the
Sabbath this is sabotage
this is the opposite of playing to your
strengths uh whatever Biden's strengths
are at this point I mean his strength is
like taking an afternoon nap that's a
strength so when he does that that's
when he's really in his element but um
reading poetry I mean it's like that is
like if
for some reason they did roll call here
at the daily wire every day where you
had to read off the names and they put
me in charge of reading the names when I
can't pronounce any names at all like
the name could be John Smith and I would
somehow mispronounce it uh Jan Smythe
it would basically be that key and peel
skit with the with the substitute
teacher but in real life which would
actually be hilarious uh you know just
like the poetry reading was hilarious
but not hilarious in the way that you
want the president of the United States
to be
so
what are you gonna do also by the way
the poem is terrible I also have to
mention
um poems need to rhyme and uh I I will
die on that hill just like so many other
Hills that I will die on and I will die
on this hill a poem needs to rhyme it
does not count poems don't count I'm
sorry if they don't rhyme they just
don't because anyone can write a poem If
it the what makes writing poetry
difficult is the rhyming part is to be
able to you know put together to put
something together and and paint the
picture in a way where it Rhymes and it
has Rhythm and but it doesn't sound like
you're stretching to make the words
rhyme that's the difficult part
so you know maybe this makes me some
kind of philistine I'm sure I am but I
still believe that poems need to rhyme
so a bad poem that was
badly told
uh from the daily wire Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis punched back at former
president Donald Trump after enduring
months of attacks from the man he
appears increasingly likely to challenge
for the 2024 presidential uh Republican
Presidential nomination
the sand has made their remarks in an
interview with Piers Morgan on Fox
Nations Piers Morgan uncensored that is
set to air later this week the remarks
from the Santos come after the former
president
has launched multiple attacks on the
governor since the midterm elections
ended including trying to Brand the
governor with derogatory names promoting
Basil's claims that Sanchez is a groomer
and claiming the Democrat the Democrat
billionaire George Soros endorsed
DeSantis
uh DeSantis has slam it was slammed by
the former president on Monday after he
spoke out against the prosecution of
Trump by the Manhattan district attorney
uh and we talked about that
um so what did the Santa say
he said and there'll be clips of this
because they're going to air it looks at
Thursday they're going to air the
interview but this is some of what he
said
he says I have what it takes to be
president and I can beat Biden this is
DeSantis now if I were to run I'm
running against Biden like uh we he and
Trump are competing for the Republican
nomination potentially I get that but
ultimately the guy I'm going to focus on
is Biden because I think he's failed the
country I think the country wants a
change he had it I think they want a
fresh start in a New Direction and so
we'll be very vocal about that
um
when asked about differences between
himself and Trump DeSantis said that
there were several uh quote the approach
to covet was different I would have
fired somebody like fauci I think he got
way too big for his Bridges and I think
he did a lot of damage I also think just
in terms of my approach to leadership I
get I get Personnel in the government
who have the agenda of the people and
share our agenda you bring your own
agenda in you're gone we're just not
going to have that so the way we run the
government I think is no daily drama
focus on the big picture and put points
on the board I think that's something
that's very important and then to
Santa's laughed off Trump's derogatory
nickname saying I don't know how to
spell the sanctimonious one I don't
really know what it means but I kind of
like it it's long it's got a lot of
vowels
that's we'll go with that that's fine I
mean you can call me whatever you want
just as long as you also call me a
winner because that's what we've been
able to do in Florida okay so
that maybe there's more to it but uh the
media has been hyping up I've seen a lot
of headlines about DeSantis uh
launches into into Donald Trump it's uh
you know the war of wards has finally
begun
um
and the vicious attack on Donald Trump
I've heard that from the media I've also
heard from Trump supporters on social
media responding to this how dare he how
dare to say this I mean all Trump has
done is is
attack him relentlessly for months and
DeSantis finally responds directly and
it's I can't believe this the disloyalty
to say anything no your responsibility
apparently as DeSantis is to just be
attacked and never respond because Trump
has some sort of god-given right to say
whatever he wants to anyone about anyone
and never have anyone say anything to
him
um that is you know uh if you're in the
cult of personality that's what some
people think
but the reality like back in
realityville right this was actually
pretty tame uh he like I said yeah we'll
see the full interview maybe there's
more in there but if that's it then
that's pretty tame all he's doing he's
asking a question he's answering a
question that was asked of him uh what
are the differences between you and you
know what Trump did and what you would
do
and so he outlines the differences
and yes he thinks he'd be a better
president he doesn't even say that but
we can assume he does I mean if he runs
for president it means that he thinks
he's qualified for the job and be better
than the next guy just like anyone else
who runs
so it's not um
yeah the media is starving for a full-on
war between DeSantis and Trump and so
far it's been basically one-sided with
Trump attacking the Santa's not
responding and now they finally get a
response and some criticism I mean
they're pretty mild criticisms really
but
um they finally get a response and so
they're going to latch on to it and try
to uh you know and they're going to wait
for the response from Trump and Trump's
going to respond in a way that's you
know that's uh far more vicious than
what DeSantis said
and that's the way it's going to go back
and forth
um
all I would say for those of us who are
conservatives and if our ultimate goal
is for a not Democrat to be in the White
House in 2024 because that is our
ultimate goal
everyone knows I'd like to see DeSantis
in there I think he's proven based on
his
um
based on his tenure as governor of
Florida he's he's proven that he knows
how to enact in a conservative agenda he
has the ability not just the willingness
to fall through but the ability to do it
I know it's it's different when you're
doing it on a national scale but
you know he has taken the opportunities
that were given to him and he has proven
that he's a capable conservative leader
and so I'd like to see him in there but
But ultimately if it's not him I want
someone who's not a Democrat I want
someone who's not Joe Biden at the age
of 82 starting a second term or if it's
not him then whatever whoever else
whatever crazy person they put up in his
place
so that's my that's what I want to say I
want to see a
uh
if it can't be descendants I want to see
someone who is not a democrat in the
White House
and if we all you know as any
conservatives if we all share that
opinion then we can't get sucked into
can't be manipulated in this way
uh by by you know pretending that like
anything DeSantis says in response to
Trump is is automatically this like uh
vicious unheard of insult right
like this kind of drama they're trying
to stir up we can't we can't allow
ourselves to get sucked into them
instead we should try to be rational and
fair at least
you're going to support whoever you
support in the primaries we should all
be rational fair-minded people
and if you're a rational fair-minded
person then you hear that and you say
well
like what else is he gonna say did you
is he gonna be asked that question and
say oh no Trump is perfect and would
make a perfect president is that really
what he's required to say come on
and what he said is true like it is just
true that that Donald Trump handed the
country over to Dr fauci uh not only
didn't fire him but awarded him awarded
him gave him an award at the end of the
at the end of it all okay awarded him
for his efforts rather than firing him
that's what Trump did and um I know
that's you know some of the some Trump
supporters are going to want us to just
forget what happened but it did happen
um
now you could question well if DeSantis
was it's all what I could have should
and it's all hypothetical if DeSantis
was in office would he have fired fauci
he says he would
no way to know for sure
I think based on his track record the
very good reason to think that he would
have
and this is what he has done in Florida
he's he he is not afraid to fire people
like this he's actually gone into the
government agencies in Florida and clean
these people out
all right
um State Department spokesperson John
Kirby insisted Tuesday that lgbtq plus
rights are a core part of the United
States foreign policy Kirby's remarks
came during a White House Press briefing
following a question about whether it
was a concern for the state department
that Russia may be attempting to
influence Africa's uh anti-lgbtq
movement to drive a wedge between it and
the U.S
oh right and of course because
you know in we know in in Africa in many
of these African nations and cultures uh
they are not on board with the LGBT
agenda they're not on board with any but
they're not on board with the with the
Trans stuff I I encountered that
firsthand as you know in uh what is a
woman they're not on board for it and so
what we hear of course the media is as
well it's because Russia right uh it's
all Russia Russia is manipulating the
African nations to be against uh the the
LGBT stuff right
but John Kirby had an answer to that and
uh here's what he says
and then President Biden has been
nothing but consistent uh about his uh
belief foundational belief in human
rights and lgbtq plus rights are human
rights uh and uh we again back to the
earlier question we're never going to
shy away and be bashful about speaking
up for those rights and for uh for
individuals to live as they deem fit as
they want to live and that's something
that's a core part of our foreign policy
and it will remain so
now LGBT rights are not human rights
human rights are human rights okay you
don't you don't need you don't need to
uh divide it and come up with different
labels and categories and subcategories
for human rights human rights human
rights uh you know human rights are
it says declaration independence are
endowed by the Creator they come as as a
consequence of our human nature and
they're the same for everybody
so if you are a gay person do you have
human rights well obviously everybody
does
but do you have special categories of
rights are there like special additional
rights that you have if you're in one of
these protected groups no
um at least not now those rights can be
invented by the state as they are so for
example you know if the Democrats they
want to give and they have in many cases
given trans or trans identified male the
right to go into whatever bathroom he
wants that is not a right that's enjoyed
by anybody else or if it was enjoyed by
anybody else so that's a special right
privilege that they want to give to this
group and so when they say LGBT rights
that's what they're talking about
because if they weren't talking about
those special additional rights then we
wouldn't need to say allergy rights just
say human rights
when they when they uh specify in that
way you know that they're just like when
they say women's rights you know very
often they're talking about the right to
kill a baby
that's not a human right that's not a
right that is endowed in Us by the
Creator
and that's not a right that's enjoyed by
all human beings men don't have the
right to kill a baby
so as a special privilege if we can call
it that
the satanic privilege that is uh that
that the Democrats want to give to the
women that have
so it's the same thing here
these are these are um
these additional rights that are that
are granted by Government powers they
are not uh inherent to our human nature
they are not endowed by God certainly
not
as far as LGBT rights being a core part
of our foreign policy well this uh if
that's the case and it is for this
Administration
that is just to say that the
administrations this administration's
current foreign policy is their real
foreign policy the real strategy is to
take all of the worst parts of the
foreign policy of the past 30 years
and then make it even worse
so to embrace all of the worst aspects
of the foreign policy of you know
American foreign policy of the last 30
years and amplify those bad parts
it was bad enough when we were
gallivanting around the globe trying to
export democracy and a quote way of life
to places that didn't want it and
shouldn't have been forced to have it
well now we're still doing the same kind
of thing but we're trying to export the
most left-wing aspects of this way of
life
and these are the aspects that are the
most
viscerally objectionable to large swaths
of the world
Those portions of the world that we're
trying the most to impose on
um
all right Fox Phoenix has a very
important story I wasn't sure if we'd
have time for this but it is like I said
it's just uh really they're doing
important things
over there in Arizona so let's let's
watch this
governor it's not even executive order
this afternoon Banning discrimination on
the basis of natural hairstyles or
Texture this would apply only to state
workers and contractors but the governor
says she wants to send a message Fox
10's Irene Snyder spoke with some
stylists about what this means Irene
well good evening John and Christina
Governor Katie Hobbs signing that
executive order today Tempe and Tucson
already passed similar bans and while as
you mentioned this is not going to be a
Statewide protection the governor saying
she hoped she hopes it will inspire
future legislation
this is our hair to have a freedom of
doing like whatever to our hair is very
powerful hair stylist Kiara Jones says
she knows what it's like to be
discriminated based on her chosen
hairstyles she's seen it with clients
that are Gilbert Salon too the times my
clients will sit in my chair and they'll
be like okay so I'm very limited of
styles because I'm going to this job and
you know I'm the only one that looks
like me
Governor Katie Hobbs signing an
executive order today Banning
discrimination against state employees
and contractors because of natural and
protective hairstyles I'm hopeful that
this inspires legislation to end this
kind of inequity across the board it's
often referred to as the crown act which
stands for creating a respectful and
open workplace for natural hair this
includes Styles often associated with
race like braids twists and locks for
the stuff that we're doing on his hair
are two strand twists Styles is kind of
like endless you can do braids you can
be very creative with brave Shantae Fox
owns a salon in Tempe specializing in
curly textured Styles she says many of
her clients in the past have damaged
their hair trying to conform to straight
hairstyles using heat and hair relaxers
it can be damaging to the hair follicle
I can't I I can't deal with that
I'm not in the mood I'm never in the
mood
for this these Damned clowns like
everything that's happening in this
country you know you got a crime wave
epidemic economies and shambles
everything and and and and this is what
they're focused on
you know we are such a stupid society
and and can we get stupider I know we
can so don't answer that question
protected hairstyles what
this is what you're worried about
is discrimination against hairstyles
the and by the way it talked about all
the you know the the very real epidemics
and crises that we face in this uh
in this country and in the world
like I said yesterday I think it's these
people Democrats would would add
additional uh crises that I wouldn't
even mention I mean these are the ones
that say that we're the world's about to
end because of because of global warming
they think that I don't
do you think the word the world is on
the brink we're on the brink of global
destruction
and you have time to sign a bill like
ensuring people can wear braids to work
and where do we get this idea I mean
this I know where we got it from this
victim mentality but you know so
rhetorically where do we get this idea
that that only black people are subject
to dress codes involving hair
so if a black person is told well this
is the hairstyle you know these are the
kind of hairstyles you can have on this
job oh my goodness this is a this is
oppression how could you say this to me
I have everyone has to deal with that
get over yourself we all that's jobs
that have dress codes which many do it
applies to everyone okay if you went to
a job where they said
um
if you're black there's a dress code if
you're white there isn't now if you
encountered that at a job then I would
agree that that's discrimination but
that is not happening anywhere that has
never ever happened to you never and it
never would
so the most that's happened to you is
you've gone to a job where there is a
dress code that applies to everyone but
because you are in keeping with the
theme of today a raging narcissist who
has become a psycho your victim
mentality has driven you psychotic
because of that you assume that this
dress code that it that that involves
everyone and affects everyone and that
everyone has been abiding by for decades
with no problem is somehow a personal
attack on you individually
foreign the correct response from
society to someone like that is shut the
hell up and get over yourself like go
cry about it you're crying because you
can't I want to wear braids so what who
cares just wear the hairstyle they're
telling you to wear that's it that
should be the response but uh because we
are again a very stupid Society instead
we hear people complaining about this
and we say oh tell me more about it that
must be really hard for you
oh you had to you had oh you had to
change your hairstyle like I can't
imagine that
no one has ever had to do that before
they are the first one
that's so desperate for victimhood so
desperate that this is what we are down
to
protected hairstyles
um all right
we have one more thing here
that is uh also important well not
important at all but I want to mention
it the uh the latest Media Matters hit
you up you know because apparently we
aren't providing them enough fodder just
based on what we say every day on all of
our shows now they're going back and
they're combing through uh Media Matters
is our entire like catalog of old videos
and
um Ariel Drennen who's a male employee
at Media Matters found a video from a
bit that all of the hosts filmed a
couple of years ago on Valentine's Day
and I forgot that this existed that we
even did this but
um the basic gist is that our wives
were asked questions about us and then
we were asked the same questions and
whoever's answers lined up the best with
what the wife said won and uh I don't I
think I think Drew won this this uh he's
been married the longest it really was
not fair
um anyway Drennan and uh a bunch of
leftists who reacted this clip were
especially offended by uh and by the way
they were
I know as soon as they saw that this
clip existed that we did some kind of
Valentine's Day you know bit fake game
show thing involving you know talking
about our relationships with our wives
as soon as they saw that they knew that
they had hit a jackpot because they knew
that they're automatically going to be
able to find something offensive like
it's impossible in their Twisted
worldview it's impossible for a straight
male
to say anything about his relationship
with his wife that won't automatically
be offensive and so
um they really had their pick of the
litter on this one and uh this is what
they this is what they decided was
offensive let's watch it
all right Matt uh it's kind of a trick
question because I I hate them both
equally so I but I guess I would say
I would rather do the dishes but I'd
prefer if she just did both of the
things Michael to you dishes it's no
question I'm not sure in our entire
marriage if I've ever done a full load
of laundry so I think I have that one I
like it all right Drew well this is a
trick question because I have not done
anything around the house for over 40
years I've been a completely useless but
it's it's clear that if I had to choose
it would be it would have to be dishes
because she was just out of town for a
month and I actually called her up and
said how do you do laundry so I think
this is the only thing I know how to do
all right to the answers Ben you
answered dishes Mrs Shapiro said I'm not
sure Ben knows how to do laundry so I'll
go with the dishes which he does quite
often and she threw in a little thanks
hun Matt you answered
I hate them both but dishes your wife
said dishes and she also threw in he
doesn't know how to do the laundry again
things are going to the bus true Michael
you answer dishes your wife said neither
but if there was a gun to his head he
would choose dishes
and Drew finally you answered I don't do
anything but the dishes if I had to and
your wife put again in all caps here
very forceful answer since he doesn't
know how to do laundry as we learned
when I was out of town for several weeks
I'm guessing it's the dishes
you caught us you caught us we're uh we
are we are normal people and men who are
in normal happy marriages and we have a
sense of humor and our wives do too
you caught us you caught us red-handed
you caught us red-handed being in
healthy well-adjusted normal marriages
where we have a sense of humor about
things caught us I don't know what to
say I mean we we and and I know uh a
sense of humor and a happy marriage are
two things that nobody at Media Matters
has ever had or will ever have and so
for them this is like shocking stuff
um
and and just so you know like some of
what you saw there I know I have to kind
of break it down for uh you freaks um so
a lot of what you just saw there it's
called Uh and uh it's a it's called a
joke okay and joke's very interesting
where it said jokes how you spell it and
um so this is this is what's this is
what's called it's like just being kind
of humorous and laughing about something
um
do I know how to do the laundry
technically
of course I do it's like you just you
throw the stuff in and you hit the
button it's not that hard you put the
detergent in of course we know how to do
that now as far as sorting the laundry
by color or whatever and all that kind
of stuff or checking the labels on all
the dish all the all the individual you
know items of clothing to see what
setting to put it on
I'm not going to do that do I know how
to do it can I read the label physically
and I can but I'm not going to do that
so I take it's more of a Kamikaze if if
ever my wife makes the mistake of
you know putting me anywhere near the
laundry I'm going to take a more
Kamikaze approach of just you know it's
it's Kamikaze style throw it all in
there and whatever happens happens
um in fact just recently I did a load of
laundry and everything came out pink and
my point was
it's kind of a fun game you know you
just throw stuff in you don't know
what's going to happen you don't know
what color it's going to come out you
don't know how how what size the things
will be when they come out of the
laundry uh you never know it's a lot of
fun it's kind of like a game
um my wife doesn't appreciate that
approach as much so I don't do much of
the laundry
and that's fine that's how you you know
this is this is a thing people do in
marriages and it's like in normal life
where you're kind it's kind of Hyperbole
and but it's it's sort of not and you're
joking around there's a grain of truth
to it uh again that's like a it's
being a normal human that's stuff that
comes with that it's that it comes with
that territory
but you see just how angry
these people are at normalcy they really
hate it which is why you know
they always it's it's it's it's it's
always so easy to predict ahead of time
what bits and what things people in
Media Matters are going to take and try
to blow up and make a big thing about
because it's always I always know
at the end of every show I can look back
and say what are the most normal Common
Sense things I said today of all the
things I said what were the most normal
and Common Sense things and it's always
going to be those things that they are
going to post and say you can't believe
what Matt Walsh said this time
because they really hate normalcy and
they don't and they've never experienced
it and they don't understand it and uh
and that's all fine
um though I will just another thing I
really it's very important for me to
clarify is that I also hate doing the
dishes so I don't want you to think that
I am Pro dishes at all
um
fortunately though now my uh my kids are
old enough or they can really start
doing a lot of those chores so I've been
able to offload that as well
it's been great
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
the blame
baby gang
Elizabeth Weaver says the Uvaldi
shooting story just makes me think of
the C.S Lewis quote we make men without
chess and expect of them virtue and
Enterprise we laugh at honor and are
shock to find traders in our midst and
uh and then to add to it we screened
about toxic masculinity and are
surprised in our hour of greatest need
to find no masculinity at all absolutely
tragic and I'm heartbroken to think of
the families
um
yeah I mean that that applies in general
applies in this case as well I mean you
can also add to that and say that uh
you know we we in in particular we were
very concerned when I say we I mean at
least the left you know the culture very
concerned about talks of masculinity
specifically
in law enforcement where they it was it
was a big concern and uh well
there was none of that in Uvaldi so
congratulations
um
Jelena says not only did The Little
Mermaid in the original film want to
leave the sea before she met the prince
the original tale is a love story a
tragic one yes but a love story
Hans Christian Andersen wrote it as a
metaphor for his love life or rather for
his love for a man that he could never
be with
so I that that's I I had never heard
that before I looked it up after you
read after I read your comment that The
Little Mermaid was originally written by
Hans Christian Andersen as some kind of
you know gay love affair or at least a
gay infatuation is what led him to write
this story and it's kind of a metaphor
for that and the story was inspired by
that and so I did look it up for what
little I read I spent about three
minutes researching that claim and from
what little I read um this sounds sounds
like a highly speculative Theory
uh based on like someone else's
interpretation of various different
things and a letter that he wrote and
all the rest
um he certainly never came out and said
that's what the story was about to be
was supposed to be about
so I don't know
um I I find it kind of dubious but but
either way it does go to show again
that these old classic fairy tales are
they are very layered and uh there's a
lot going on
and off and often they have some pretty
dark elements in fact most of them do
look the classic fairy tales um it's uh
you know there's love and there's
romance involved and there's all these
different things and there's magic and
everything but it's also it's also can
get quite dark
um
yet in modern times we take these
classic stories that have been around
forever
and we add Nuance to them just like uh
the Halle Berry
which was the The Little Mermaid the new
one Bailey Hallie Bailey
like she was saying yesterday we were
talking about so well we want to add
Nuance we're making it more nuanced
but every single time you're adding
Nuance to the story
by taking the Nuance out of it but the
taking all the depth and all the layers
and everything like taking all that out
and uh and coming up with something just
like this sterilized kind of even even
aesthetically when you look at these uh
these live-action remakes of the old
cartoons
and yeah the themes they they've they've
neutered all the themes and all the rest
of it they've made it even more
politically correct than it already was
even though many of these stories as we
said yesterday were already pretty
politically correct because a lot of
these cartoons were made in the 90s
which wasn't exactly I mean it's not
like it is now but it wasn't exactly uh
you know
um I mean there was the PC police were
already a problem back then but
um
on top of that aesthetically like you
you end up with something that's just
it's not nearly as vibrant or
interesting it's just kind of gray and
washed out and
ugly and boring and
um so that is their version of adding
Nuance their version is to take all take
all of it out
uh
Nick says hey Matt I lead the college
Republicans at Kent State yesterday we
had a screening of what is a woman and
we had a huge turnout I have now been
accused of genocide and all of our ads
for our club around campus were ripped
down by the tolerant left any tips on
continuing influence on campus in the
future thanks
well the one thing I would do is I would
put up put the ads back up and do the
screening again
when they get mad at you for doing
something that's the rule number one
they get Maddie you're doing something
do it again keep doing it
uh another comment says Matt if the
aesthetic in your office doesn't fit the
giant walrus then you went for the wrong
aesthetic
that is uh you know that is a rebuke
that I will that I will take and I will
take into consideration but I still
don't want the walrus in my office only
because I want the whole family to be
able to enjoy it
uh Jay Anderson says I mean we all knew
Matt desperately needs therapy but after
him ragging on Ted lasso if as if it had
committed some personal offense proves
once and for all this poor man-child is
broken
like I know uh these are these are these
are hard sayings for many of you you
don't want to hear it about Ted lasso I
think what happened here's my theory to
tell us because because again when you
watch that show
mildly Charming for an episode or two
and then it falls off a cliff
and uh and it's really quite terrible
but and not funny at all you know any
attempted humor most of it falls flat
and the writing is bad and lazy and
uh also by the way in some of the later
episodes like very woke it's it's always
interesting to me the people that you
know are are rightfully sensitive to the
welcome they don't want to be subjected
to that they don't want woke moralizing
and yet there are they they they make
exceptions in certain cases and so Ted
lasso there's a lot of wokeness in that
show all over the place not even like
isolated incidents of it
um and but for some reason that's looked
over I don't know why
so yeah I get but here's my theory why
why how did that show become so popular
my theory is that it came out in the
summer of 2020.
and I think people were you know a lot
of people have been locked in their
houses for for months and people are
going stir crazy from the lockdowns and
I think that's what it was I think I
think it just came out at that time
when people were uh stir crazy they were
also like starving for human connection
and uh and then they come along with
this cheesy show about soccer and for
whatever reason people latched on to
that and so there's this emotional
attachment but if you can if you can
look past the emotional attachment you
will see that objectively
it's not a good show
old school says I hereby nominate
Michael Knowles for your next daily
cancellation if I'm not mistaken he
basically likened you to a lib because
of your deep founded belief in Aliens
well funny you should mention that
that's coming up next
you know I'm not going to lie to you
because I don't have to and I refuse to
I don't like shaving it's why I have a
beard but what I really don't like are
leftist razor companies that hate our
values yet feel entitled to our money
it's why I spite them all by buying Ray
Jeremy's razors and Jeremy's beard kit a
year ago Jeremy's uh declared war on
woke Incorporated with the launch of its
six bladed founder series razor after
taking in feedback from all of you
something Jeremy is much more willing to
do than I am a second razor was soon
developed the new Precision 5 razor is
crafted with a hefty tungsten handle
five welded steel blades and a flip back
trimmer for a smooth precise shave
around beard lines sideburns or whatever
uh you got going on with your face over
a hundred thousand men have already made
the switch to Jeremy's and it's time you
did the same stop giving your cash to
so-called Men's Grooming companies who
hate men and use your dollars to fund
radical left-wing agendas let's put woke
Corporate America out of business go to
Jeremy's racers.com to get your
Precision five razor and Shop the
growing line of beer care skin care and
hair care products today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well I want you to know to start with
that I never wanted it to come to this
uh but I have been left with no choice I
must today cancel my friend and
colleague Michael Knowles
of course I've known for a long time
that Michael is not a believer in Aliens
I've listened to him repeatedly slander
the alien believer Community ABC
and I have shown great and admirable
restraints using not to respond in kind
but now he has crossed a line so for a
little bit of background uh and behind
the scenes here yesterday as I was
passing Michael in the hallway on the
way to to film my show after he had just
filmed his he excitedly shouted to me
hey I talked about aliens today
and he was baiting me to watch the
segment and I took the bait I was
expecting it to be ignorant and
factually Incorrect and it lived up to
those expectations or down to them but I
did not expect the level of vitriol and
hate that I encountered
he launched a vicious defamatory
broadside against the entire ABC even
calling me out by name which means he's
attacking the ABC and the SBG the ABC
SBG he stopped short of saying that we
should be eradicated but I know he was
thinking it you know there's been a cold
war over the alien issue at the daily
wire for years now
but now Michael Knowles is firing shots
uh here's the clip another story I had
to get to today
this is out of UCI
the University of California Irvine
Terminator zones on distant planets
could Harbor life
you see Irvine astronomers say
these in between regions could be prime
sites for liquid water
in a new study University of California
Irvine astronomers describe how
extraterrestrial life has the potential
to exist on distant exoplanets inside a
special area called The Terminator Zone
which is a ring on planets that always
have one side facing its star on one
side that's always in the dark
and the thing is
um
no they couldn't
the thing is I'm not even going to read
the rest of the article I'm certainly
not going to read the study
uh no the Terminator zones could not
Harbor life because extraterrestrial
aliens aren't real they're not real and
the limbs just they love it they were so
fascinated by it it's just it made me
think
about how many completely ridiculous
things the libs believe in and yet they
call us the gullible ones they call us
the Fantastical ones
the libs believe in catastrophic global
warming it's going to kill us all in
five minutes the libs believe that boys
can secretly be girls and girls can
secretly be boys and the libs believe
in E.T it's not real there is
I know this is controversial on the
right I know my colleague Matt Walsh
here is very Pro ET there is
zero evidence
that extraterrestrial life exists
anywhere
zero the the best evidence second
musters well the universe is really big
okay yeah
okay first of all why are you reading
off of an actual piece of paper this is
the year 2023 what are you trying to
prove do you do show research with the
Dewey Decimal System too I mean I
believe in returning to tradition but
let's be serious here
second
I don't know why I'm asking about shell
research it's clear on this topic anyway
they don't believe in research you claim
that there's no good reason to believe
in alien life but then refuse to read
anything that might threaten to explode
your bigoted E.T phobic preconceived
notions that study from UCI which you
printed out and then discarded literally
murdering trees for no reason says that
planets orbiting red dwarf stars could
it in fact have the right conditions to
Harbor life now this is significant
because it vastly expands the number of
extrasolar planets that could
potentially have life you're correct
that the size of the universe does not
itself indicate that there's life
elsewhere in the universe indeed if we
lived in a vast Universe hundreds of
trillions of light years across and
there were no other planets and we can
assume that aliens aren't real as you
say but in fact we do live uh we do not
live in an endless vacuum with only one
planet orbiting one solitary star we
live in an endless vacuum with billions
of planets orbiting billions of stars
the existence of the planets
doesn't prove that the planets are
inhabited obviously and we know just
based on chemical composition and
atmospheric conditions that a large
portion of them are almost certainly not
inhabited but that still leaves billions
of planets where the potential for Life
exists each planet is potential and that
potential is repeated billions upon
billions of times you say there's no
evidence of E.T that's that's true in
the sense that we haven't seen like an
alien skyscraper through a telescope or
whatever but we can calculate the number
of potentially habitable planets and
that number goes up all the time so
there's evidence of et's potential and
that potential is repeated in
essentially infinite number of times
possible that you could visit every
planet in every solar system in every
Galaxy and even after spending trillions
of years on that sightseeing tour still
find not one living species anywhere
else that's possible but it's not the
most likely scenario
okay you certainly have no rational
basis for assuming it and you definitely
have no rational or evidentiary grounds
for declaring from the outset that
there's nothing to find in the first
place
by way of analogy consider this you know
we now know that there are something
like 3.5 trillion fish living in the
oceans 500 years ago we knew very little
about what lived there people came up
with all kinds of wild theories many of
which ended up being incorrect but the
the sheer size of the ocean
was evidence in itself that it probably
contained billions and trillions of
living creatures
uh so yes the fact that the ocean was
big was reason enough to speculate that
there's probably billions and trillions
of of fish in it that was an assumption
that could be reasonably made and it
would have been irrational and
ridiculous for a person 500 years ago to
assume that the ocean only contains the
number of fish that he can see when he
stands on the shore and looks out that's
what you're doing in essence you're
standing on the shoreline and saying
well I see a horseshoe crab and a clam I
guess that's all there is and if
everybody was standing on that Shoreline
with you and nobody had seen any more of
the ocean then we would have to admit
that your assumption could prove correct
but even without checking we would still
know that it is not the most plausible
Theory
yet you're doing something more absurd
here because you're standing billions of
miles away and declaring that all of the
oceans and all of the land on all of the
planets and all of the solar systems in
all of the galaxies are all empty
now
let us examine the charge which you make
later in the clip
uh that and and you making what we heard
there that I am a lib on this issue I
will concede that whoever is the most is
most the lib when it comes to the
question of alien life is the least
likely to be correct there is of course
an inverse correlation between liveness
and correctness you say that I'm the lid
because uh because you know Libs want to
believe that human beings aren't special
and uh and that could be achieved by
postulating the existence of other
beings in the universe
but that is not my position
now I can't speak for the actual Libs
who may or may not believe in alien life
but what I can say for myself is that I
know human beings are special because we
were made by God and we have rational
Souls I also know that God has chosen to
place the human species inside this in
fact unfathomably boundless Universe
populated by something like 700
quintillion planets they create all
these planets and all these galaxies the
vast majority of which we will never see
not even in a telescope only to keep
them all empty
possible I suppose but he also may have
created them in order to fill them with
life which will glorify him in ways that
we perhaps will never understand I would
submit that insisting on an empty
universe is an attempt to limit God it
is to say that God must operate in ways
that we understand and that he cannot
have created an other life on other
planets because the existence of such
lies life raises questions that are
uncomfortable for us
this I would say is Huber's as for the
specialness of human beings
why would humans be less special just
because other life exists is each
individual human less special just
because there are eight billion of us
there there were 400 million people on
Earth 500 years ago today there are 8
billion has our individual stock somehow
gone down just because we now find
ourselves on a planet far more popular
than anyone in the 16th century ever
could have imagined no not at all
and so if I am not worth any less no
matter how many people live on Earth how
would I be worth any less by the
addition of life on planets I will never
visit or see anyway
human beings are not Commodities whose
worth is determined by the law of supply
and demand the universe
could be teeming with life and I believe
it very well may be and that would not
undermine our Worth or our purpose by
one iota
we have our place on this vast Cosmic
tapestry even if that tapestry is far
more alive and vibrant than you assume
and that assumption that assumption if
anything
makes you a lib sir
and a scoundrel
and it also makes you today
that'll do it for this portion of the
show is move over to the members block
uh you can become a member today and use
code walls to check out for two months
for you on all annual plans hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]